[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 14
décembre
china moses et andré manoukian était au
prisme le temps d'un concert à travers
de grands classiques et jazz et sol
il parlait d'amour difficile le week end
dernier trois solistes de la ville d'où
on se retrouvait à trappes pour jouer
les trios de schubert des oeuvres ode à
la nature et le grand public les connaît
grâce à on n'demande qu'à en rire une
émission d'humour
majid berhila et les jumeaux ou fait
rire à gorge déployée
les ai mis mon temps c'est une histoire
de coup de foudre un coup de foudre
musical un comté hier soir à elancourt
china moses et andré manoukian était sur
la scène du prisme de sinatra armstrong
en passant par jessica rabbit
les deux artistes ont proposé des
torches sont des chansons d'amour
impossible
regardez une entrée délicate au piano
andré manoukian installe la soirée et
prépare le public est l'arrivée de china
moses une voix teintée de jazz de sol
la force de sa voix l'érotisme de sa
voix naturellement mais surtout et le
timing alors le timing classe est
important parce que veut dire qu avec
elle je joue avec un batteur je joue
avec une section rythmique j'ai pas
besoin de faire tout le boulot de toute
la pompe au piano du coup j'ai plus qu'à
faire de l'espace et en ayant même tempo
tous les deux
leur concert parle d'amour à travers des
tortues song ses chansons d'amour
impossible qui font mal un style rendu
célèbre par louis armstrong ou encore
frank sinatra china moses et andré
manoukian collabore depuis 2010 et un
album un véritable coup de foudre
artistique
on sait très bien trouvé en fait avant
moi je tournais j'avais des répertoires
avec un pianiste et nîmois qui s'appelle
raphaël lemonnier et quand on brême a
invité à participer à son projet je le
faisais ma file item fidélité musical
déjà et j'ai découvert le avantage
d'avoir deux pianistes dans sa vie et
j'aime bien dressé un super musicien et
et en plus on apprend toujours quelque
chose entre m avec lui
un plaisir à jouer ensemble visible dès
le premier morceau un dialogue amoureux
qui se laisse contempler
[Musique]
on continue avec de la musique classique
ce week-end les spectateurs de
l'auditorium de trappes ou passer une
heure avec franz schubert trois solistes
de lavilledieu avait choisi
d'interpréter deux trios du compositeur
autrichien
retour sur ce concert avec des images de
nicolas d'anglais
trion numéro 1 de franz schubert un trio
pour piano violon et violoncelle et
créée en 1827 par le compositeur
autrichien
schubert a vécu à peine 30 ans donc
effectivement il a été composé un an
avant sa mort
donc ce sont des oeuvres de maturité on
dit aussi que des libérés parce que
beethoven pierre juste de mourir donc il
est libéré de l'emprise de beto c'est
vrai dans ces dernières années il
s'exprime clairement il sait qu'il est
condamné parce qu'il est malade et donc
il sait qu'il est condamné
donc il ya tous acquis qui transparaît
schubert un pilier du mouvement
romantique de la musique de chambre que
ces trois solistes de lavilledieu ne se
lassent de reprendre et de proposer au
public saint quentinois
ça fait longtemps que je les joue je les
connais je les travaille et retravaille
et puis voilà ça mûrit un petit peu avec
vous voilà et après ça on évolue avec cd
le propre des chefs-d'oeuvre c'est qu'on
évolue avec eux et ils vis avec vous et
cdc des oeuvres qu'ils sont c'est comme
quand vous lisez vous un grand roman
quand vous les avez attendre vous voyez
pas les mêmes choses vous disais pas
même chose quand vous le lisez à canton
près de deux siècles plus tard les trios
de schubert invite toujours voyage dans
l'esprit du compositeur l'amour et la
nature ils ont tous les trois a acquis
une certaine célébrité grâce à on
n'demande qu'à en rire
une émission d'humour présenté par
laurent ruquier 2010 à 2014
majid berhila et les jumeaux étaient sur
la scène de la salle jacques brel
vendredi soir une soirée placée sous le
signe du rire une soirée 100% humour
j'ai joué quatre ans avec sur scène et
d'après mes calculs niveau roulage de
pelle ma femme est en deuxième position
depuis 2014 majid berhila n'est plus
ryan des lascars gays
pendant trois ans le duo qu'il formait
avec hugues duquesne participa on
n'demande qu'à en rire
l'émission moore de laura gautier majid
berhila joue maintenant seul sur scène
j'avais envie à un moment donné d'être
moi sur scène j'ai envie de m'exprimer
correctement sujet vers des compléments
ne pas avoir cet accent de banlieue et
j'avais envie de me dévoiler je pense
qu'à un moment donné c'était bien de de
partir sur d'autres choses
j'avais envie d'être moi tout simplement
ses inspirations son enfance en picardie
l'arrivée de ses parents du maroc sa
célébrité issus de l'émission majid
berhila veut casser les clichés
le tout avec dérision autres artistes ce
soir là les jumeaux eux aussi issus de
l'émission leur force une folie douce
qui parle de tout et de rien et cela
nous a vidé la piscine
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
oui surprendre à chaque fois on s'est
dit que à chaque fois que les joueurs
arrivent on sait pas ce qu'ils vont
faire à ce que cette délimitation de la
parodie est ce qu'on est en costard
comme on est sur scène faire du stand-up
des sketches on s'est dit que pourquoi
limite se focaliser ce poids zone et si
on peut faire beaucoup de choses
leur vie les inspirent mais aussi la
politique
un univers mouvant qui les oblige à
modifier sans cesse leurs sketches en
temps je suis très content des tricheurs
amandine est le premier jeu réussit un
petit peu pour me détendre un petit
vieux pour me consoler d'une certaine
façon parce que vous le savez les dames
ans chez ge et éliminés du premier tour
en plus des primaires et mémé dénoncé
une exposition maintenant à découvrir
sur la mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville de
guyancourt
l'artiste daniel convenant présente ses
oeuvres jusqu'au 28 janvier de la
peinture bitume sur toile un matériau
qui l'a découvert en 2008 et qui est
devenu sa marque de fabrique
au coeur de ces créations la figure de
l'arbre daniel convenant s'interroge sur
la notion du temps de la vie de la
mémoire il était au micro de camille
lambert
enfin représente le temps
c'est le but ça vient du pétrole qui lui
même qu'un des matériaux ont des
compositions des matériaux comme le voit
et tout ça est donc pour moi c'est ça
représente le temps soyez des les
nuances énorme que je peu à peu en tenir
avec le même matière c'est donc avec le
même un saut avec un même mais même là
même un médium je fais plein de choses
pour savoir quoi regarder dans les
salles de cinéma on écoute luc beau
quand le directeur du ciné 7 d'elancourt
nous donne son coup de coeur notre coup
de coeur aussi dès cette semaine a
évidemment on peut pas y échapper
c'est un groupe one pardon aux stars war
stories qui sont aujourd'hui dans nos
salles
donc c'est un spin off un spin off c'est
à dire que c'est un un dérivé de
l'histoire initiale qui situe entre
l'épisode 3 et l'épisode 4
les connaisseurs apprécieront et me
suivront et qui raconte comment les
rebelles ont volé les plans de l'étoile
noire
nous pensons qu'il peut nous aider quand
as tu vu ton père pour la dernière fois
c'est quoi ces questions
alors c'est très réussi pour un spin off
on pouvait avoir des craintes en disant
que ça va pas être purement commercial
chez carat c'est très réussi c'est très
sombre
on retrouve des personnages des épisodes
précédents des épisodes suivants
il ya des surprises on peut en parler on
a laissé les spectateurs de découvrir
voilà mais c'est dans nos salles à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est dur 2h14
notre rêve
et puis un peu cool kikuku aussi au film
d'emmanuelle bercot qui ça se pèse la
fille de brest qui est encore de nos
sacs qu'il faut absolument voir avec
emmanuelle bercot c'est à la fois une
grande actrice et une grande
réalisatrice je pense à mon endroit par
exemple de maïwenn où elle joue les
formidables et elle réalise aussi très
bien et ça raconte l'histoire du
scandale du médiator
c'est aussi avoir dans les sections il
n'y a pas de vraie compassion peur tous
les résistants on perds tu crois
[Musique]
à vos agendas plusieurs rendez vous
culturels à ne pas manquer c'est l'un
des ballets classiques les plus célèbres
la belle au bois dormant
il ya comme ça ne valait pose ses
pointes au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 17 décembre
vous pourrez redécouvrir l'histoire de
la princesse aurore accompagné de la
musique envoûtante de tchaïkovski dans
son corps et tout spécialement pour les
enfants dans pop up gardel le jeune
public et à contribution ça se passe à
la ferme de bel ébat de clients cours
nous regarde un extrait
[Musique]
du jazz maintenant et c'est au prisme
d'elancourt samedi 17 décembre avec le
quintette du batteur et compositeur
vincent touche à un concert aussi entre
la musique de jazz et la musique
classique
ça débute à 21h un dernier rendez vous
et c'est de la magie alain choquette
manie aussi bien la magie que l'humour
l'artiste québécoise sera ce week-end
sur la scène du théâtre espace coluche
de plaisir
regardez cet extrait car ce soir j'ai
l'intention de vous divertir de vous
mystifié mais surtout de vous traiter
comme des rois
vous avez reçu une enveloppe vous allez
délicatement
on va faire de la magie en semble prenez
maintenant la main droite vont mesurer
et vous les replacer êtes génial le
cetud culture est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
l'émission peut se retrouver en replay
sur le site de tv fil 78 passé une très
bonne soirée jeudi à mettre 10 prochain
[Musique]